المقارنه مشروعه لانه ايضا عندنا توجد
حركات التطرف يوجد حركات يوجد تكثير توجد
مشاكل كيف يمكن ان ننكر ذلك نحن نعيش ايضا
حاله
تستدعي همم تجديد فهمنا لتراسدا العريق
بتراسنا الكبير العربي الاسلامي وبالتالي
هناك تشابهات لا توجد تطابق ولكن هناك
كما قلت لك اتحدث فقط عن
السادس عشر النهضه رغم انه عصر عظيم تحدث
صيدا عن القرن الثامن عشر الثامن عشر
صلاح
الدين
[موسيقى]
وهذا يتشابه ما بين الاسلام والمسيحيه
هناك تشابهات لا احد ينكر انه يوجد عندنا
مشاكل اليوم ايييي
التطرف زلاميات تكسير
حروب مذهبيه الى اخره ما بقدر نستطيع ان
نرتب وجودها الان اوروبا تخلصوا منها
تخلصوا منها 200 سنه يعني 100 سنه 50 سنه
يعني هذه المسافه التفاوت التاريخي ما بين
التقدم الاوروبي والتخلص اااه الاسلام
العربي الاسلامي هناك همم
يخص
فهم الدين
والتنوير الديني